hello my voice did not agree with me
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to troll face quest this is
a game that was often requested by you
that's a class game on Newgrounds you
can find in the description below and it
involves a bunch of ridiculousness a
bunch of er e that I'm going to
involve myself in right now
so let's play oh yeah I do
cool thanks you know this isn't exactly
like what I thought saw would be like as
simple as that
I mean obviously this game is gonna be
about a whole bunch of dick at read okay
looks very happy about me being dead
maybe this is cuz he's a dick
gonna be something under his trench coat
there well I can already tell this game
I'm gonna drive me to drink isn't it uh
I need an excuse oh that's what you did
in the last level so that's what we need
to do okay oh that makes no sense at all
but I gotta think like a troll I gotta
go back to my 4chan days when I did all
this crap oh oh I see well this is like
The Incredible Machine except oh I'm
dead great that was good I'm glad I did
that so what am I supposed to do
Oh
oh it didn't work I don't know how that
would have worked I guess I'm just an
idiot fine Oh
always got so many choices that's the
way okay all right then so what you're
telling me is that I need it seems to
involve a lot of pp well oh I wasn't
supposed to let the bull die why was I
not supposed to let the bull die oh look
it's dude born again is dong okay all
right okay cool I don't know what that
what is that a rabid snowman Christmas
anymore oh oh oh oh god oh god it's to
kill detonator oh no it's my firming
equipment
doc come on you you piece of
what are you gonna do that to me
okay so what am I supposed to do here
come on
I wasn't doing anything it's fire right
there there feels like a good spot to me
whoa whoa why did that work why was that
the one that works why is that Worthen
oh that doesn't make me who you should
touch that don't be a good idea for you
to do go over there and touch it with
your face preferably stick your nose
right Hank okay oh I don't know oh maybe
I shouldn't
oh okay then okay click ten times on the
troll face come on Wow are we having fun
Oh bit more bit about bit about little
bit of a little bit of the word all my
training from the impossible quiz has
kind of made me good about this 50-50
Wow
maybe I'm gonna do it again ah maybe a
little my luck it's just going against
me all right cool
Amy's dead so for the friend that didn't
seem to help at all
fresh balls is saved up oh okay oh is it
candy okay
but I didn't press next level in time
Oh me I'm too smart for you bonk
okay so I dodged that obstacle but was
that gonna do for me honk you want to
throw another obstacle at me because I'm
pretty good BAM oh okay oh wow York I'm
a whale hork
let's try this I'm a loser I'm a smarty
puss and these guys ain't smarty at all
oh no buttons I didn't know it didn't
work yeah baby
maybe maybe you deserve to die I don't
know I'm starting to misinterpret the
logic behind all this in the game
there's a green god 100 odd Oh No do I
really have to present a hundred times
what do I need to press out or dive oh
well let's get into hyper mode here and
you bastard oh let's get
back into hyper mode this is what I can
do with my finger oh this looks good how
about this welp at least you didn't die
from the kill detonator four thousand
that you can buy for dad you can't buy
this toy you're dead how about this
maybe drinking before death is not the
option okay maybe I should let things
maybe I shall let bygones be bygones and
just see what happens I'll probably die
but you know what I'm ready to accept
this fate because frankly this guy's an
idiot
it was a button oh it was a button up
there oh I saw the button it's the last
minute put my reflexes were too slow
because I rather didn't care about the
main character dying I'm gonna push this
button and I'm gonna push it so good oh
you are going to love my button hole
face and Tenzing oh my reflexes are just
so fast did I cause it
one of you bastards is hidin ain't you
so smart jump I'll jump now how's the
old now is a bad move don't tell on the
last one apparently okay musical notes
was I supposed to remember that boo boo
boo blah okay I'm dead music's not okay
oh no oh no if we come full circle for
your inquest Oh
flippity flippity oh so that's magical
what you did there
hello again how you okay okay I guess at
the end of trollface quest great I'm so
glad I did that with my life but you're
in luck everybody because there's
actually two more games after this so if
you want to see me play those games and
lose my mind just a little bit more than
I have already which is a lot then let
me know in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other stupid games that I played in
the past in the description below or in
the annotation over there thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video do my best troll face
huh problem officer
now many people know that the trophy is
originated from the cool face it was put
on your cool face he was being pulled
over by a cop there's a comic you can
find it